president Trump claiming victory after
the release of the Muller report I'm
having a good day - it was called no
collusion no obstruction there never was
by the way and there never will be and
we do have to get to the bottom of these
things I said in front of my friends
this should never happen to another
president again this hoax it should
never happen to another president again
Trump's reaction coming after Ag William
bars news conference where he once again
cleared the President and confirmed
there was no collusion and no
obstruction so that's the bottom line
the special counsel confirmed that the
Russian government sponsored efforts to
illegally interfere with the 2016
presidential election but did not find
that the Trump campaign or other
Americans colluded in those efforts now
the focus has turned to obstruction some
Democrats are insisting that President
Trump broke the law but AG Barr says
that's not true the report recounts 10
episodes involving the president and
discusses potential legal theories for
connecting those activities to the
elements of an obstruction offense the
Deputy Attorney General and I concluded
that the evidence developed by the
special counsel is not sufficient to
establish that the president committed
an obstruction of justice offense
although the Deputy Attorney General and
I disagreed with some of the special
counsels legal theories and felt that
some of the episodes examined did not
amount to obstruction as a matter of law
for more on what's inside the Mullen
report let's go to Ed Henry ed oh good
to see you guys certainly after this
report was released Rudy Giuliani texted
me this was quote unquote a knockout
blow for the president when it comes to
his critics that after 22 months and 25
million dollars the story did not really
change much today Attorney General
William Barr made it clear yet again
just as he did in his letter to Congress
last month the special counsel found no
collusion by any Americans with Russia
including Trump aids Barre specifically
declaring
while yes Russia tried to interfere in
the last election they did not get help
from Canada Trump or his aides that
despite congressman Adam Schiff other
Democrats repeatedly claiming they had
evidence of collusion robert muller
never found it despite thousands of
subpoenas hundreds of warrants witness
interviews and the rest
despite democrats in various pundits
repeatedly hinting Donald Trump jr. was
going to be indicted over that June 2016
Trump Tower meeting the bottom line from
the Mulla report is it was not criminal
that is part of volume 2 of the Muller
report which is more damaging to the
president because the special counsel
details ten instances where the
president acted in a way that raised
questions at least about obstruction of
justice smaller declaring in his report
quote while this report does not
conclude that the president committed a
crime it also does not exonerate him
bottom line this is shifted now from a
legal fight to a political fight shift
declaring to reporters a few moments ago
this is not game over for his
investigating of the president while
Giuliani seems delighted about more
investigations which he sees as partisan
Julianna just texted me again a few
minutes ago saying quote the
commentariat is reeling guys Thank You
ed Henry all right so I've been going
through this whole report big time today
feel how listen everybody that's how big
it is and I have a color-coded tool and
we're gonna refer to those color codes
later Marie I can't wait but Dad I
wanted to get to you first I know you've
been following the story very closely
the way I see it is the president for
two years has been falsely accused of
being a traitor yep Muller has now
concluded the president is not a traitor
and the Democrats instead of being happy
that the President of the United States
is not a traitor they're angry about the
way the president fought back against
the false allegations that he was a
trainer right they're angry that the
president was angry that he was falsely
accused of selling out the United States
is incredible let's be clear on this
there was never evidence of collusion
ever and this report is a disgrace
whoever wrote this report Mahler
Weitzman and his team of Democrats
framed it in such a way to leave out
very significant facts one there's no
evidence of collusion in there because
they couldn't fabricate it but when a
guy took two notes on this when you go
to the Papadopoulos section well there's
a lot I'm talking about on this alone on
the Papadopoulos section they leave out
the fact that you
Masoud the guy who allegedly tells him
about the Russian emails had deep
connections to Western intelligence to
go look it up on Google if his pictures
are out there with UK intelligence
people second on the Trump Tower meeting
they strategically leave out that the
Russian lawyer that shows up was working
with the same company working for
Hillary Clinton kind of relevant right
to the story but no let's leave that out
it's a disgrace this obstruction thing
is a joke the president is fully
vindicated Oh any rational person
reading that knows it yeah and if you
listen to Rudy Giuliani who said on our
air earlier that the Russian lawyer met
with fusion GPS the dossier authors the
day before the Trump Tower meeting and
every day of and the day after must have
been a coincidence all right Greg you've
been going through the report all day I
know now your top on conclusions not I
haven't read it and you know what I'm
never gonna read it I swear I'm never
gonna read it because this is not news
to me if you were conscious on March
24th you already knew it that was called
a spoiler alert
when you were told there was no
collusion in no obstruction so this is
the second time around for me and it
feels pretty good it's like you know
around Christmas time they play die hard
and you love die hard the ending is
great and the ending is always the same
you know John McClane wins Hans Gruber
dies okay now this is the difference
between America and the rest of the
media America watches die hard and knows
the ending and enjoys it the media
watches die hard and thinks the endings
going to change that somehow Hans Gruber
is not going to die and John McClane is
gonna be arrested so they didn't in
three weeks now they watched die hard
twice and they've had their hearts
broken I love this CNN's ratings are
very low right now but the ratings they
have I believe are based on comic relief
I think that people are going there and
watching it just for the hilarity I want
to address the one thing mister was this
him it edy Henry is that same what does
he work we he's one of our oh great nice
guy he ran through the laundry list
fallacy he mentioned ten instances that
raised questions okay you take each
instance on its own it doesn't raise any
it says it's there's nothing there so
instead you step back you go but there
are ten but if there are ten zeros
ten times zero is still zero so that's
called the laundry list fallacy that if
you don't have a strong argument you
have ten small arguments that you add up
and you end up with this obsessive
obsessive fascination at which they're
not going to go through the report and
look for little zeros there's gonna be
an entire industry devoted to solving
Bigfoot and the Loch Ness monster that
was also your point during the Cavanaugh
hearings and if you just keep throwing
and throwing more and more allegations
at them yeah it just builds up into
something more different now the Hogs
Gruber of the table just kidding Alan
Rickman was a great actor how do you see
this report on obstruction molar makes
clear in the text of the report that
they are not saying no obstruction he
says that in plain language we are
unable to reach the judgment that the
President did not commit obstruction of
justice right he just didn't charge him
with obstruction those are two very
different things Jesse and he outlines
legally why he could not under the
existing Justice Department guidelines
charge the president he outlines a case
for obstruction and then in plain text
says it's up to the Congress to decide
if this obstruction of justice which by
the way has been part of two articles of
impeachment for Nixon and Clinton
obstruction of justice
it's rises to the level he actually said
if Congress wants to do its own
investigation they exercise that very
clearly he doesn't say this was the
product of here you go Congress take it
where I love it
he said if they want to do their own
investigation they can find it too
that's not actually what he said but he
very clearly closely the sense here is
pretty close reading um but he said very
clearly I am NOT saying the President
did not commit obstruction of justice he
also does not say there's no collusion
he says there's no conspiracy or
coordination that rose to the level of
criminal standards so he is not and then
he outlines very clearly multiple
contacts between the Trump
administration and Russians nostalgia
my final point on that to answer Dan's
question I think we should have higher
standards for our president than whether
things are illegal I read this and
thought it may not be illegal
I find it abhorrent I find it unethical
I think it's nothing that any other
Democratic or republican your rights
than you if you were rights than you I
don't think that any other presidential
campaign democratic or republican would
ever engage in this kind of behavior I
don't want my presidency have less we
have less rights I mean to me release me
release that I wouldn't have released it
I'm just trying to be clear the meeting
with Russians is illegal now or is
unethical trying to accept help to
influence to read the actual report what
do you five minutes it's amazing
speed reader yeah what is the flag stand
for that is redacted information there
was just one little nugget that I was
I've been curious about and he find out
that there's actually nothing there so
go way back with me back in time to the
2016 RNC convention and the language of
the platform gets changed on Ukraine
right that we were going to support with
arms and then it gets watered down and
it was like how did that happen I'm like
I actually wanted to know how did that
happen and I thought maybe like manna
for it's got a little side deal going on
maybe it turns out no it's like a gun
snap elections a gun I don't know how
old he is but like a not important level
staffer that thought they heard the
president at some point think that maybe
he would rather do it this way and so he
gets it changed but for almost three
years there has been this suspicion out
there that there was a change in the RNC
platform based on some sort of nefarious
thing regard in regards to Russia know I
want the name of that staffer it's in
the report actually